the Joe Rogan experience you know
now when you did the Wolfman was there a
push to do some sort of CGI version of
that was it did you have to like either
a discussion about how to do it I
expected that it would do it CGI because
everything at that time was basically
CGI and I had a friend that got a copy
of the script and I read it in a red
like a CGI thing hmm and I was actually
filming at Universal we were filming
some of the Norbit stuff at Universal
and I went to a a producer there that I
knew who was a visual effects producer
as well and I asked him if he knew
anything about the Wolfman you know
because I said I didn't love to do this
you know that's one of the films that
made me do what I do you know and and I
said is gonna be CG and he goes no
actually they were talking about it
being a makeup and I go will you put my
name in there then you know I would love
to do this so they the original director
wanted it to be a makeup and I thought
we were gonna do transformation we
actually built stuff for a
transformation it was a weird film in so
many ways it seemed like you know
Benicio was great to work with he wanted
to he wanted to be the Wolfman you know
he's a monster a real monster kid too
you know Anthony Hopkins was great you
know III did it with my friends David
who else he but III think we were the
only people that wanted to be working in
a movie called a Wolfman
I mean think everybody else was
embarrassed that they were working in a
movie called The Wolfman really yeah and
they would do things the production
manager called me into the office once
and said what is this why are you by
buying all this hair what is this hair
for I go seriously
why do you need this hair and he had a
big behind his desk at a big sign said
Wolfman and I went and covered it up and
cover up the wolf park with my hands I
go right now we had this a man I'm gonna
make him a Wolfman and I need hair for
that why do you need hair because wolves
have fur it's like what the [ __ ] I can't
believe I'm having this conversation
with you you know because what I mean do
you need all of that hair you know I
mean what and they like that through the
whole movie it's just so embarrassing
you have to talk to someone
like that I know but then I'll just let
you do whatever you do I know and you
know I think people who are in industry
who have to deal with this stuff all the
time to think that I never have to you
know write it happens all the time
you know and it seems like everybody has
to yeah yeah and but I mean it was very
frustrating but again Dave and Lou Elsie
and I we we had we'd worked day and
night and when everybody was gone we had
the best time you know we're working a
Wolf Man movie you know and when we
first filmed the sequence in the gypsy
camp where this all these gypsies mhmmm
and fog and stuff is like you know
that's what was it was very reminiscent
of the old movies but like a new version
of the old movies yeah with the fog and
the gypsy camp and all that jazz it was
really similar to the original launched
Annie yeah there was also a junior yeah
and he had kind of a hammer film feel to
it too you know and we and Anthony
Hopkins makeup was it was you know a
little more curse the werewolf
Christopher dr. sir I was gonna say
Christopher the way was his name Oliver
Reed Melina had that kind of feel to it
and and I mean like I said Benicio is a
real big fan of the horror films and we
got along great in fact he would come
into the makeup trailer with old monster
magazines and that he bought on the
internet and there he is
and he would quiz me on stuff you know I
know what's this I knew everything I
knew it you know everything on every
page you know and we became we connected
we bonded over that you know the scene
where he makes the transformation in the
medical theater uh-huh that was a great
scene it's a whole CG though does that
all see jzg oh it's basically it's based
a lot on ideas that I had you know
because I I mean what I said you know
because they said well we got to do the
great transformation like American wife
and I said American Werewolf we had a
naked man who changed into a four-legged
hound from hell
right here we have Benicio del Toro and
we have benissa disorder with some hair
on his face you know and some teeth
right we can't the the changes aren't
the same we can't stretch out his body
we can't write you know well we wouldn't
have that same kind of feel so I said
well how about if we do things worse
fingers twist and do it uncomfortable
and stuff like that right but we
actually made a lot of stuff but it's so
weird I mean like the production we
weren't even invited to this set when
they did the transformation even though
he had stuff they didn't want you to
know they didn't want me there why is
that I don't know they didn't want your
input
you know I guess even though it's a lot
of the what's in there is based on some
animatics that I did and some drawings
and stuff but it was a really weird deal
I mean it's like we were the unwanted
children in that movie you know that's
so crazy for me to hear something like
that it's so it's stunning because I
would have assumed that in my eyes
you're Hollywood royalty like you're the
guy who made American Werewolf in London
you're the guy who made so many these
incredible movies with makeup and
special effects I would think they'd be
pumped that you were there well yeah I
thought that too no but it wasn't the
case but you know I mean I you know
something interesting when I read this
book the on my career I complain too
much about the film industry and I
shouldn't because it's been really good
to me I mean I like I said it was my
hobby and I made it a decent living at
it and I got Awards for it and I got
free food and things you know and it is
magic I mean you you you it's like time
traveling like working on this movie
when we're in you know London in areas
that haven't changed since the 1800s and
you have all these people and period
costumes it really is like your time
travel you know and you get to work with
some really amazing people yeah see this
is all CG really well done CG is really
well done yeah and and Steve Begg who
was the visual effects supervisor was a
a really great guy and he was really
upset that we weren't able to do this
stuff as well but they think they did a
terrific job and I you know I like CG to
a degree I mean I I like the fact that
it's another technique that we can use
to do things that we can't do in the
real world with rubber yeah right right
I just don't like that they do things
when we can do it you know and I think a
lot of it comes down to Oh before
American Werewolf I would have to try to
beg people to let me do something I mean
it was like
can I put a mustache or and a scar on
this guy you know and after American
warrior wolf I would get scripts with
stuffing and I had no idea how the hell
I was gonna do and I like crazy crazy
stuff but they they would say to me what
because they did a lot of interviews
after American War often they said what
is the material that changed that
allowed you to do the work that we
haven't seen before and I said I got
adequate time and adequate money and it
was the first time I had that and after
that I like when I did gremlins - I had
a year's prep but the problem is I need
answers a year before we start filming
because I need to make this stuff and
usually a directors on another movie
then and doesn't want you know
eventually after I hound them I'm trying
to get an answer will give me some kind
of answer which just to make me shut up
you know hmm CG all that stuff comes in
post the film's already made you kind of
cut it together they start making the
stuff but this is obviously makeup that
is yeah so was CG until transformation
till he's the werewolf and then when
he's the wear of this was done in a
different day yeah well I mean they the
CG was done all imposed Yeah right
but yeah him sitting in the chair was
Benny stealing the day and this is
that's actually the stunt double and so
sometimes when he was running he was
running on all fours yeah and onion leg
extensions and most of that stuff is
Spencer Wilding who was her stunt double
there's there are some shots of
close-ups this is Spencer the stunt
double yeah but that was what was weird
about it it's like he's running but he's
got kind of like dog legs
yeah but he's running on two legs
yeah with dog that's been easier but it
was it was a hybrid you know of American
werewolf and the original Wolfman yeah
you know the Wolfman had you know he
said he stayed on his balls of his feet
you know he didn't try to get that
illusion of like dog like original one
yeah yeah
and you know I it's so funny because I
walk like that as a kid though all the
time you know I did do things and so
could Dave Elsie but when we tried to
get the stunt guys or even Benicio to do
it they couldn't do it we couldn't walk
on their toes on the balls of their feet
like that with their heels up you know
I don't know you know at in a second how
come I can do it but it's also something
a skill I developed as a child where is
[Applause]